hi it's over at again and please excuse
me here as I'm struggling to talk like a
normal human being because i'm currently
got a sore throat but you know i still
have to keep this stuff going on and I
really haven't recorded any videos
before hand I used to have many videos
saved which was actually a good idea but
I haven't had that in a very long time I
haven't been able to play a lot of
roller coaster in three as of lately and
that's kind of one of the reasons why I
don't do that anymore and that's also
one of the reasons why my current
planning doesn't seem to be too well
logical I suppose that's something that
I'd like to talk about because I talked
about this in the last video and
actually got quite some comments about
this as well it's the fact that I don't
have a schedule and I indeed don't and
it might be a good idea to have that but
then again I only really play this game
when I really want to play it and when I
really feel like playing it and actually
enjoy doing something and especially a
particular project and I don't want to
be forced to do or well release certain
videos on certain times I just want to
enjoy stuff and I suppose that also as
one of the main reasons I don't want to
have this become like a job or anything
like that this is still a hobby and I
still try to release as many videos as I
can sometimes and actually keep the
diversity going in them but I don't want
to force myself to actually do that this
is still a just a hobby and I am already
kind of almost forcing myself to do
certain things and that's also something
that I wanted to talk about and I
actually wanted to do this later on but
it's it's about silver city I'm actually
planning to cancel silver city as in not
totally abandon it but quickly finish it
and move on to a new city because I've
kind of reached that point where I feel
like I can do something better than that
it feels like the park has derailed in a
way that this park hasn't though this
style was very similar to all of the
buildings that i already have by the way
just kind of talking about what's going
on right now i was planning to make a
little facade with amsterdam ish
buildings just a couple of very narrow
buildings together to kind of form a big
facade using which I can kind of film
that corner because there's nothing
going to be there's nothing to really go
on over there
but then again I don't want to have
forests either and why didn't I cut out
this part with the pipes because the
game crushed and then I lost all that ok
so I'm so restarting with that but
anyway that's not how I feel about
silver city because I really do feel
like the city isn't all that good and I
don't want to I know when to tell myself
that my city sucks I I'm someone happy
with some of the buildings but it's the
real to point where I don't feel like I
really want to work on the project
anymore and this has happen very often
with many projects when I wouldn't
record them as a let's play and now it's
actually happen with a project that I
did record as a let's play and I usually
wouldn't just end it right there so what
I'm going to do is just create a couple
of small episodes adding some extra
buildings in there and then just
finishing the rest off with foliage
that's really all I'm going to do just
gonna place big forests around it and
then create a video of it because I do
feel like I want to try and go for
something more realistic and it's not
because I'm not interested in the park
anymore because that's that's usually
why you drop a park and then never come
back to it I'm actually more interested
than i was when i started with it and i
started doing some more research on
buildings and I've actually got a better
idea in my head of what I wanted to do
because the more I built in Silver City
the more I felt like no this is not
handing in the right direction entirely
so that's why I want to work on that
again and really the thing that's going
on in this park isn't all that
spectacular I'm still afraid that
everything is going to be too similar of
what I already have but you're gonna see
in a while what I'm going to do with
that because basically what I tried to
do in this case is like I said before I
kind of wanted to have a antique ish
well influence in here and i took that
influence into the small arcs that i'm
using in the buildings that i'm
currently building here but i'm actually
going to build a very big building in
the neoclassical style and that brings
us to the new style or a everyone ok the
new step is the new styles are going to
be neoclassical spooky Alpine steampunk
with i lost all of the other themes
it's going to be all the stupid stuff
that are going on already but with
classical elements loads of classical
elements so that means all the good
stuff we're used to piped and the wood
stuff and all that good jazz but with
with pillows those sexy pillows really
those classical things are just too sexy
I'm kind of almost I don't know I want
to do something with my new park
something that I've rarely tried before
or something which i haven't released
too often but then again this Alpine
okay there's a couple of things that I
really like Alpine I've covered that in
this park I like medieval covered that
in this park and really it's been done
to death really so I kind of want to
avoid that as well then there's
classical of course which I've already
done so don't really want to do that I
do and not so good at spooky stuff I
know I added some spooky influences in
this point but it's not all about that
all about that bass and then there's
something else which I steampunk yes
steampunk but everyone's been using and
abusing steampunk as of lately so I kind
of went to back off from that as well so
I don't know exactly what I'm going to
do but I've got it I've got a couple of
ideas one idea that I might just go for
his asian I've never ever did and on a
true asian theme I know I did that one
Asian coaster which was elf but there's
nothing else and it didn't really have
Asian theming in terms of buildings for
some reason I thought that I could use
the English victorian style with
Japanese foliage I have no idea where
that came from but that's what happened
with that coaster but I actually do want
to go for a real asian park perhaps this
other idea that I had is to go for a
Baltic theme as where does that sound
it's kind of like medieval and Alpine
but then again it's known and it has
like the northern European influences
and everything it's hard to explain it's
kind of like I've heard somebody explain
that Estonia is this like a country
stuck in the medieval times and I
ellicott well laugh at that and I know
that many people actually refer to it as
Shrek theme I don't know it kind of does
look like that but like yeah that's
basically what I want to try some Baltic
thing
what is that I just like the countries
and I just like the cities and all that
but I have never ever seen anyone try
that and I do kind of want to think
outside the box and actually do
something which not many people I've
done before then there is the option to
do an African park but I'm not too
interested in that so I'm probably gonna
not do that and I probably also suck at
that so really there's no point but it
would be cool to make like a zoo or
something it's still my plans but
definitely not in them well in the near
future I suppose and then there are just
other small ideas but really I think
it's going to be either Baltic or it's
going to be um yeah that just asian and
that counts for the city as well what
I'm probably gonna do is I'm I well I
might do this actually but I if I make
an Asian city for example I I'll decide
to make a Baltic park and if I make a
Baltic park I'm just gonna do an Asian
but that's when i said already if i'm
going to do a agent Park I'm just gonna
do a belt except it was that what I said
well but you get the point anyway I keep
forgetting things like I said I even
forget things I said one minute after I
said it that's how amazing I am i doing
that but yeah this is basically going to
be that classical building that I've
talked about earlier and I have no idea
if this is going to work it might just
turn into a huge feel that might very
well be the case because what is the
idea behind classical Alpine spooky
stuff like look at that who I actually
used the spooky chimneys from station
Jim's haunted ghost cabin thingy and I
don't know if that really makes sense
but it looks cool so I just decided to
go with it but I'm gonna finish this
building in the next episode and
actually see if it's gonna work out then
because I still don't have a clue what i
want to do with this building especially
the spire I mean this Penniman not too
sure what to do with that but anyway
that's all for the next episode so see
you then